foreign
[Laughter]
oh my God is that terrible
[Music]
hi everybody I'm serayah and I'm Paul
from aew
and you are watching snack Wars on sport
Bible today we're going to be trying UK
Foods as well as American foods first of
all because I'm British and I'm American
right yeah yeah Eagle noises
let's get stuck in
this is interesting I've never seen this
before uh I don't think I have either Dr
Pepper cotton candy this is interesting
what does that look like
oh that doesn't look good does it look
it looks like it looks like somebody put
a lung in a package smoke is long yeah
very good all right let's try it look at
this thing it's like a science project
it's got the texture of stuff you put in
chairs
doesn't it
you like it sounds like it
it's like but my first thought is I just
ate a big cat furball yeah I know okay
this is like a proper oh this is cute
from m s food made with real fruit juice
Percy Pig
why would you put
pork product
or candy that's just weird anyway all
right yes it keeps on giving it's like
we're gonna have a little Percy Pig
I'm not mad at it I guess it's kind of
like a whole Gummy Bear the texture is
just different the flavor is nice well I
think definitely Percy Pig over the
couch stuffing
okay A W root beer versus Iron Brew I
don't even know how to describe that
it's got a dude lifting on here is this
like a sports drink
I will do oh it's orange
we're keeping the same glasses root
beers and those uh yeah I'm that OCD I
know
[Applause]
Jesus
[Laughter]
on that one
oh my God is that terrible what does it
taste like
um vanilla vomit
[Laughter]
like I mean that's really terrible
that is horrendous you take another step
just in case no it's it's so bad I can't
believe it tasted that bad hungover
hung over like it's like medicine I if I
was hungover I'd rather like have a
grilled pork chop out of an ashtray
like that is just there's nothing I
think we're gonna drink it again I'm
amazed that this is actually a product
it's very popular too
yeah stop drinking it's so bad I can't
stop maybe that's why it's popular yes
because I can't get a taste on it I'm
like oh this is good or no it's like no
this this is rotten
oh
it's root beer I'm not a root beer fan
nor am I if I had to choose
um
starting to grow on me
I will take one for the team and go for
team Britain if he likes it
better than the root bed I think that
smells better than the root beer yeah
um
what the it smells like like a medicine
for us yeah it does it smells like yeah
it does it smells like medicine you're
right I've never been a root beer fan
like the quickest way in the world to
screw up ice cream is put root beer on
it in my opinion cold float I'm in a
root beer float no
[Music]
but I mean I understand I'm a giant so
my taste buds are completely different
they're heightened actually so who gets
the point It's gotta be I would say iron
Brew Over root beer yeah wow that was a
roller coaster
[Laughter]
oh wow oh I love Scotch eggs oh they're
so yummy yeah they're good okay I like
America McDonald's yeah obesity running
rambit McDonald's
although don't feed yourself you know at
3am really hungry a hot Big Mac I mean
yeah use your giant hands to rip it but
it's delicious it smells like a donut oh
it's definitely not a donut what does it
go it's not gonna like squirt them no no
it's because I'm not cool with it I'm
just letting you know I got my limits no
sweating if it squirts on me we're done
it's boiled okay yeah you're safe
textures are weird I used to eat these
like a cider pad
smells good
mmm
oh
no is that the first time you've had one
yeah
that's good that's really good it's just
pretty much sausage meat fried crumbs
and this is like a great breakfast thing
yeah like you know that warm you could
eat that on a go no mess no fuss
um
all right and you know first of all is
it really a Big Mac
I mean it could look cute look at the
look at the comparison right now
yeah I feel like I got The Hobbit Big
Mac
all right
that's not good though
it looks like a Big Mac yeah it's got a
joke should win this one because you can
get these anywhere I'm gonna agree with
you to me for a more exotic taste I'm
gonna go with Scotch egg too come on I'm
not sure exotic taste in Scotch egg have
ever been used in the same sentence to
me it's very exotic just uh the textures
take just take it this is our one thing
that we can be called exotic for a
second yeah I mean geez come on I mean
I'm garbage guts you throw anything my
way I'm gonna eat it
thank you
is that pot noodle oh my childhood right
here okay
this is all you eat when you don't
really have it no no it's pot noodles so
it's just noodles and it is delicious
mac and cheese mac and cheese America
yeah oh yeah I'm gonna try the mac and
cheese yeah let's try it I'm tired of a
snob when it comes to mac and cheese me
too me too
yeah
that is not a quality magazine that's
not a quality mac and cheese I don't
know whoever made it I'm sorry if
they're offended but that's the
drizzling the British person making a
mac and cheese yeah that's a drizzling
what's it missing
um flavor
it just like I don't know it's very very
please take this away yeah that's an
epic fail because like it has like an
objective like my mac and cheese that I
make as a crispy crust it's layered
there's different cheeses
um the noodles are cooked better like
it's an emotional experience we have my
Mac and Cheese yeah you're having to
move that was an emotional experience
but not in a good way get it together
England you're embarrassing me
all right let's see this is a god this
reminds me of being like really broke
it's like Ramen noodles yeah it's not
toothpaste sandwich broke because I was
that broke once
oh yeah trust me when you get hungry
you'll eat anything yeah I would eat
salad cream sandwiches
um yeah that's a pass
try this one the Bomb Bag what does it
taste like
I did something spoiled
[Laughter]
those look so tiny in his hand freaking
crazy yeah
they look disappear in his clothes
everything happens when I hold it with
my hands it's very disheartening yeah
his Fork is just like
this is much better than ramen noodles
yeah you have a lot a different stuff in
here yeah that's a lot more tasty than
whatever the hell that was I would
definitely choose this over that yeah
that is not good point to the UK then
went to the UK and I think it's kind of
red because if UK made that mac and
cheese and obviously they're not from
the south where macaroni and cheese is
that's right sacred whoever made that
should be taken out back quietly
and the UK wins yeah
[Applause]
well played good care somehow I feel
like I've won because I got to eat even
though it may be a loss I still want it
ah just rubbish I think it's some sort
of like fish spread or something but
it's oh can I swear on this go ahead
awesome
that is so bad